yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
Pixar's latest offering finding Dory
sees the animated hit makers dip their
toes back into the sea of sequels after
treating us to two original features
last year a follow up to 2003 Finding
Nemo finding Dory sees the forgetful
blue tang move from sidekick to center
stage in a fishy tale which focuses on
her search for her long-lost parents
screenwriters Victoria Strauss and
Andrew Stanton who also directs
alongside Angus macLane have rounded out
Boras character highlighting not just
her sweet and funny side but also
lending her more depth revealing the
fears and worry she faces due to
short-term memory loss and as the voice
of dory ellen degeneres is fantastic
bringing all those different shades
their character to life this time he
also gets a young version of dory - the
way she's animated in flashbacks is oh
so adorably cute and slow Murray and
Lucia Geddes do a great job lending
their voices to baby and tween versions
of the absent-minded fish as well as
bringing back several Finding Nemo
fixtures including Nemo himself and his
dad Marlin finding dory introduced us to
a whole range of wonderful new
characters of the newcomers a grumpy but
ingenious seven tentacled octopus called
Hank who's brilliantly voiced by Modern
Family star ed O'Neill gets the lion's
share a screen time and what a fantastic
addition he is to this underwater world
making a great Odd Couple with dory
providing tons of laughs and extra heart
- as the nearsighted whale shark destiny
and the rather melodramatic beluga whale
Bailey Kaitlin Olson and Modern Family's
Ty Burrell add loads of lovely moments
playing really well off each other and
also Ellen's story and it Rachelle burr
and Dominic West sunbathing sea lines
are an absolute hoot there are also some
pretty cool cameos in the film with one
in particular used in a clever way
that's guaranteed to bring a big smile
to your face whenever you hear it as it
expect from Pixar the animation is
top-notch with an array of gorgeous
scene setting familiar and new ocean
locations from the coral reef to kelp
forests and lots of interesting land
bone the cows provided by an aquatic
rehabilitation center on the California
coast there is a feeling about finding
Dory that were retreading some of the
same water we covered in Finding Nemo
both thematically and in terms of some
of the ocean set scenes in particular
and it's not as nuanced as Pixar's best
but there's still lots of fun to be had
with some great characters humorous
moments and action filled sequences that
make the movie worth watching as well as
an underlying message which emphasizes
the ability in disability which deserves
to be heard and while Pixar's last
feature the good dinosaur had more
grown-up human than I first expected in
a movie that was more squarely pitched
at kids than say inside out finding dory
doesn't quite hit the creatively clever
heights that we've come to expect of
Pixar when it comes to adult laughs
there you'll still find a decent number
of them by the way if you're an Easter
Egg hunter don't forget to keep your
eyes peeled throughout and I'll have my
video guide to the movies Easter eggs
right here when it's ready oh and if you
usually - right out of the cinema as
soon as a film prop is finished just be
aware there are some lovely animated
moments during the credits and at the
very end of the credits there's a little
treat too so make sure you don't miss
that so to sum up finding Dory isn't
quite unforgettable but it is
beautifully animated and full of warmth
and it features a nice mix of colorful
characters and a voice cast who really
deliver the goods while it's not a
hundred percent fresh catch of the day
overall it's a plenty enjoyable and
entertaining film and on top of that the
short film Piper which screens before us
it's a lovely little delight finding
Dory gets 4 out of 5 flicks now what did
you think of finding Dory and what's
your favorite Pixar movie and why let me
know in the comments below if you liked
this review I'd love it if you'd share
it and do subscribe for more movie
reviews Easter egg videos and amazing
movie facts click the links here to
check those out thanks for watching and
see you next time yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers